I told him what I thought, and we even
kissed, and if it was so intense, then I guess we
could call it a lover.But was
that kiss really that pure?
If I misunderstood the distance here, it would
have been like kissing the president.  Is he even a boyfriend? He gets
carried away by the atmosphere and kisses only from below. He
thinks that if he kisses him, he instantly
becomes his lover. Everything else is fine. Chairman, are you okay? I'm going to have a proper talk with Shinomiya today. This is
definitely
coming.
[Music]
Shinomiya seems to have a
different atmosphere today, and if you ask me, it
doesn't impress me as much as usual.
Wow,
Kaguya-chan, Kaguya-
chan, I'm so lucky to be able to see Kaguya-chan too.
[Music]